[Music]
a wedding photographer
deletes a couple's wedding pictures
after being denied food at the wedding i
heard of that [ __ ]
it's been going viral on [ __ ]
instagram right
that's kind of petty but it's also kind
of [ __ ] up that was he got denied why
would he why didn't he get food uh
context isn't worn out no no i heard
that
he got denied so he [ __ ] ditched he
deleted everything and he just left
is that right it is but again i got to
give more context to back up the
photographer because if you were to just
hear that then it seems more petty than
an actual i thought if you're hungry
and you they're not feeding your ass and
you're working why i don't know i
thought it was normal like they're
supposed to feed your ass unless it
wasn't part of the deal or something
which is i mean gray area but let me
just go ahead and give some context just
so we make sure that we all judge this
person correctly
judgmental beings
so uh one of the friends had recently
approached this photographer asking if
they could be their wedding photographer
as they were trying to keep costs down
so it was like a friendly it's already
right yeah the homie price exactly
exactly so
uh and you're a friend that won't feed
your friend what the [ __ ] kind of [ __ ]
yeah what the [ __ ]
while this wedding photographer was
unsure at first they just figured you
know what uh their friend had convinced
them there was a friend they're saying
they didn't care if the photos were
perfect or anything they just want to
keep costing this cost down and whatnot
so uh this photographer is like you know
what uh it's a shoestring budget and
i'll agree to do it but it's only 250
bucks 250 bucks to be a wedding
photographer that's [ __ ] cheap
so cheap
dirt that's like you you might as well
do it for free
if it was 200 bucks i might as well be
like i'll do it for free feed me but the
point is
this person had agreed
agreed to shoot it for 250 right for a
10 hour wedding event okay on the
wedding day
get a shorter wedding dude the uh the uh
grooming bride and all that stuff they
had they had to drive around to go to
multiple places you know appointments
appointment because it's not just like
the reception and whatnot it's getting
ready the photographer needs to like get
the preparation photos this photos the
pickup photo bob so it was a really
really long day got to bounce back and
forth on the guy on the girls side too
exactly get the first look and so
amongst amongst all of that they hadn't
had a chance to take a break or even to
eat as they had recalled he said i
started around 11 a.m and was due to
finish around 7 30 p.m so when the
wedding days are nuts though yeah so
when the dinner service opened up for
other guests they expected to be able to
grab a quick bite to eat but it wasn't
allowed
he said i was told i cannot stop to eat
because i need to be the photographer in
fact they didn't save me a spot at any
table which is kind of normal i've been
a i've been a b wedding videographer
before and if anything you uh go to the
green room or a designated like yeah
yeah
that makes sense but you do get food
yeah a designated time a green room
johnny carson over here
but the groom wasn't in a mood to cater
to the knees that day and he said uh i
need to either be the photographer or
leave without any pay
what kind of way to [ __ ] talk to
someone like that wild bro
he should he should have spin the cake
[Applause]
um
and then so he says he says with the
heat being hungry being generally
annoyed about the circumstances he asked
if he was sure uh and he said yes so he
deleted all the photos and he took um
and in front of the guy he he literally
confirmed that he's like that's pretty
bad i'm sure that's what you want to do
and he was like yes like you go be the
photographer and then he deleted all the
photos in front of him and he bounced
i'm so petty i could jerk off to the
story yeah this is a great story because
it's clear villain yep
a hero
under duress
you know circumstances beyond his
control yeah he's literally just just
needs to eat just to i mean he's been
there for 10 hours everyone else is
hungry why wouldn't he be hungry if
that's his friend if they're friends and
he's doing it on a discount what kind of
friend talks to
yeah that's [ __ ] spicy bro that's way
too spicy way too spicy and on top of
that too it's like he's get he's giving
the photographer [ __ ] for them being on
a shoestring budget you know what i mean
that's crazy i thought it'd be something
like
actually it's good news you don't have
to eat the hot food we got you some
nature bars
[Laughter]
but it's not even that faster like this
fool was it
oh [ __ ] you haven't eaten all day yeah
man just go get some quick bites i'll
stall and then when you're done maybe
you can kind of like
you know because i get it like during
the reception that's also a huge part of
the photos and there's the dance and all
that stuff happens like the daddy
daughter dance or whatever right
but who's taking pictures of that yeah
rarely rarely do you take photos when
people are eating and on top of that too
the things that happen when people are
eating are they get served table by
table right and not until everybody
actually gets their food does something
actually there's time room for the bride
to actually walk around to each table
and do a toast yeah yeah so that's a
nice pocket so during that time the
photographers can go eat or the
videographers and it's also if you're
that tight on your budget don't have a
photographer
if you're if you allotted 200 if you
want to have a nice wedding and you've
allotted 250 dollars to your
photographer budget don't have a wedding
if your dad has an iphone you get a
photographer and you go like that
what's the point right what's the point
you're you're spending all this money on
this big lavish event right but then you
don't want to pay for someone like good
money for someone to film your [ __ ] or
you got to make pictures yeah what's the
point i love pissed off [ __ ] that's
stupid bro and there's no food this face
is so cute this fool can't afford food
that's crazy it gives you an idea of how
nick is in traffic which is why you're
my bro you're my brother you're my
brother we're brothers because it's
simple things bro it's little things and
i don't like when people are not
appreciated for what they do that's so
scary when it doesn't leave my body
points i like that that's true i like it
this bothers me keep it on that side
nick here will stand up for the little
guy and then he will also speak to the
manager for us
wow yeah i'll be like excuse me i didn't
i did not like that i'll say stuff like
that just while he's wearing his [ __ ]
fanny pack in his crocs yeah she's like
excuse me sir i did not appreciate this
[Laughter]
so what kind of vacation is this huh
i'm dressed for it aren't i
damn this is nice oh what a [ __ ] face
the groom is an [ __ ] he's a piece of
[ __ ]
damn this [ __ ] went viral though i
didn't read into the details but i it's
been going all over instagram but if i
was the groom and maybe you know he was
a little sauced and he [ __ ] up yeah
of course to the bride he didn't get an
[ __ ] huh
this guy's being a total dick that
photographer what a prickly because she
had no idea no clue
or the photographer save your complex
just like hey your groom's a dick this
guy just
because who really knows what went down
it was between those
it was a conversation between the two
this story is going this story is going
viral because it was posted on reddit
and you never know reddit's always a
one-sided place
let's hear the story of the group
dude let's hear the groom's story if you
trust a reddit story frankly
you're [ __ ] up
because like you said there's there's no
that's true objectivity ever never it's
just my side especially when the whole
like headline you think uh the
photographer that's kind of petty that's
kind of crazy it's too perfect where
he's the hero
oh [ __ ] we just got duped dude cause
like
first off why do you even why do you
have a friend like this yeah now we're
like [ __ ] because you never know because
think about it right the this is a piece
of [ __ ] friend yeah he asks you to do a
favor and he treats you like garbage
it's either he doesn't know how to
choose people around his life
or
maybe
he reacts in this way because this
photographer is weird yeah just like the
juicy sommelier just like juicy when
that story came out we're like oh my god
that is so [ __ ] up that that happened
right like that's terrible and then you
find out more details you're like
[ __ ] planned it yeah you played
the whole [ __ ] thing beat me up
still had a subway sandwich intact
wait i missed i missed the whole what
are we referencing you know juices you
see smaller
oh oh oh yeah yeah
no that's how dave chapelle said it yeah
the dude who just said he got like yeah
yeah
but he bought everything this is trump
country friend chicago at 3am
in the roughest part yeah
so stupid and he's still holding his
subway sandwich and he had a noose
around his neck but he's just like
chilling yeah he never took it off yeah
dude
for the sake of justice whatever ended
up happening to that dude i think he got
charged did he get charges he dropped
it's a bunch of [ __ ] what about his
like street cred the city was gonna sue
him for wasting the [ __ ] time of like
resources and then they dropped that's
just mine
the title of the plane now you could do
wasting
so we don't know what really happened in
this story let me let me google what let
me tell you something this guy's
probably a vegan
he walks up he's like getting vegan
options like no he's like
i'm deleting all this [ __ ]
tonight food
[Laughter]
guaranteed the case closed if we're
going to defend the photographer yeah we
have to defend the other guy too like if
we're being objective come on we got to
look at both sides here i want to hear
what the groom
why he said it that way yeah i want to
see i want to hear the groom's j-u-i-c-y
go back in photographize or you're not
getting paid
photography yeah like who talks like
that you better go back and
photographize and do what you [ __ ]
signed up to do this is wedding country
pal
[Music]
you